what we're living through is a counter
Enlightenment a reversal of
Enlightenment values themselves an
assault on reason and truth and freedom
of speech and freedom of conscience I
was really shocked the last time I was
in LA isn't you know we have homeless
problems in London and we have poverty
problems in London but La is off the
scale so they say it's their free choice
relax if they want to defecate in public
and shoot up in public do whatever else
they want to do in public that's freedom
but that's not Freedom that's
degradation that is self-degradation but
it's also social degradation
it's the unwillingness to make judgments
the criminalization of moral judgment
let everything happen let everything go
you know don't be judgy that's I think
underlying well once you take away truth
you take away Ryan wrong and then you
can't make a judgment yeah exactly
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our terrific guest today returns
to the show for the third time he's a
journalist and the author of a new book
a Heretics Manifesto essays on the
unstable Brendan O'Neill welcome back to
trigonometry hi guys pleasure to be here
it's great to have you back everybody
knows who you are at this point so we
won't do the usual who I have you got to
hear the one thing I will say is your
new book is excellent and one of the
reasons it's excellent is that I feel
like a lot of people who have clicked to
watch this maybe or listen to this maybe
like well they've had Brendan on we know
what Brendan thinks he believes in free
speech but actually with your new book
you've done a great job of introducing
some new ideas and some new Concepts and
that I imagine isn't actually an easy
thing to do in the current environment
where it seems like everyone's talking
about everything now yeah well that was
well I'm pleased to hear that that was
the aim of the book it was to dig down a
little bit more historically into some
of the ideas that people like us are
talking about freedom of speech
tolerance the new age of unreason and
how do we challenge it so I wanted to
dig down and just look at the Historical
precedence to that where did it come
from what are the similarities in the
past in relation to the problems that we
face today so I look at that in relation
to the idea of the Witch Hunt the idea
of this kind of stifling conformism that
we face today on so many issues the
cancel culture the cancellation of
people for saying controversial things
so in the book I look at how those
things have taken place in the past how
they take place in the present and what
are the links between those two
different eras so I hope people will
read the book and see that the problems
that we face today are not particularly
new they may Express themselves in a
different way but these kinds of things
have been problems that people have
based throughout history indeed they
have and I mean let's be honest Brendan
you know some of the titles are all the
chapter titles they're a little bit
provocative aren't they in particular
the first chapter title which is her
penis there we go her penis you know
when I sat down and thought to myself
I'm going to write a book on heresy
called a Heretics Manifesto I knew from
the very beginning that the first
chapter was going to be called her penis
and that the first line of the whole
book was going to be we need to talk
about her penis which is the first line
of the book I knew from the very
beginning because I thought to myself I
need to drag the reader into the book I
need to grab the reader and make sure
that they know what this book is about
and also I just think that the phrase
her penis is such a brilliant
encapsulation of the problems we face
today so the question I ask in that
chapter is how did that two-word phrase
become an accepted part of uh everyday
discussion you see in the media you see
it on the BBC and in the times the
newspaper of record you see it in courts
of law when they're having trials over
rape and sexual assault you see it from
the mouths of leading politicians and
cultural figures they will literally say
those two words her penis which in my
view is in a rational term it's a term
that would have made no sense to people
10 or 15 years ago it makes no sense to
me now I don't I I think the only
pronoun that should ever come before the
word penis is his the male pronoun so in
that chapter I asked the question of how
language gets manipulated how are we
encouraged what are the mechanisms
through which we are encouraged or
forced in some instances to say
something as untrue and regressive and
ridiculous as her penis so that that one
I wanted that how does that happen tell
us what are the mechanisms I think it's
it's various things I think there's a
there's cultural pressure on people to
buy into the trans ideology or the work
ideology more broadly there is cultural
pressure for people to agree that a man
can become a woman simply by declaring
that he is a woman
um we know there's cultural pressure
because anyone who refuses to do that is
can be canceled they can lose their job
they can be no platform they can be
blacklisted on University campuses we
know the cases of Maya fostata for
example or Kathleen stock
um Posey Parker down in New Zealand
people who have either been blacklisted
from respectable Society or attacked by
feral mobs of misogynists which is what
happened to our mutual friend Posey
Parker Kelly J Keen
um so there is this cultural expectation
that you will genuflect to the trans
ideology and that you will adopt its
language and you will adopt its ideas
and if you don't you face punishment you
will be did a heretic so I wanted the
first chapter of the Heretics Manifesto
to be on the issue of trans and on the
issue of a phrase like her penis and
what that tells us about the
authoritarian times we live in and it is
a very authoritarian time because it's
asking you to deny biology and fact and
you in the book I think you give an
example of Caitlyn Jenner
yeah well
one of the most I think what the reason
the trans ideology to me is so
interesting in relation to the question
of heresy and the way in which we're
forced to believe certain things and
banished from public life if we refuse
to believe them is that the trans
ideology as you say absolutely demands
that you reject the evidence of your own
eyes reject the light of your own reason
and instead bow down to what the
establishment has degree decreed to be
correct and right and truthful and it's
it's really is astonishing another
example I give in the book is the New
York Times and the BBC a few years ago
they published an article about a woman
in her 80s who murdered and decapitated
another woman a woman who was in her 60s
and I was reading this thinking hold on
women in their 80s don't murder other
women I can't think of any instance in
my lifetime where that happens they
certainly don't decapit protect them
women in their 80s tend to be quite
small usually a bit frail certainly not
murderously inclined so I'm reading this
thinking what the f is this about you
get to the very last line in the BBC
article and it says this is the trans
identified person you get halfway
through the New York Times article and
it says this person was previously a man
previously identified as a man so it's a
man it's a man who murdered a woman so
you read something like that and you
think to yourself they're lying to us
they're gaslighting us on a daily basis
they're saying things to us that are
simply untrue they're saying to us two
plus two equals five which is what
happens of course in all worlds 1984 and
if you if you disagree if you say
actually two plus two equals four and
this woman that you're talking about is
actually a man you will be branded a
bigot you will be cast out of polite
Society you will be demonized so I was
very very interested in the way in which
gas lighting has become utterly
mainstream it comes from the mainstream
media the New York Times and the BBC
these are esteemed media Outlets who are
telling us that a woman murdered a woman
and it was simply untrue and what coming
back just this is one of the things I'm
thinking about a lot I think I was once
probably under the impression that this
is all driven by the sort of pink haired
people on college campuses but
increasingly I'm starting to to be
persuaded by the idea that
a lot of people are going along with
this because it's easy because they
don't want to have problems at work
because they don't want to be the one
they don't really care it doesn't really
affect them and if it does they'll sort
of make peace with it because they don't
want to make a fuss and it seems to me
like it's almost like those people are
far more numerous and therefore far more
dangerous than the people who may be
expressing these ideas out loud in in
Extreme Ways yeah I think it's a it's a
mixture of different kind of responses
to these problems
and then the question that I'm always
asking myself is how these ideas get
institutionalized I'm so interested in
how consensus is forged and enforced I
find that such an interesting topic of
our times so I think you're right so
there are the True Believers I think the
pink head people on campuses and in the
trans Lobby itself they're the True
Believers there are also the political
opportunists there are sections of the
labor party sections of the media
establishment who really go along with
this because they think it's a way to
demonstrate their virtue to prove that
they're down with the new ideologies and
with young people so they really run
with it too kissed armor is a perfect
example when he says 99.9 of women don't
have a penis which leaves you know
hundreds of thousands of women who
potentially do have a penis so he buys
into that irrationalism because he
thinks it will benefit him politically
and then there are lots of other people
who I think don't speak out now I'm
generally quite sympathetic to those
people because I think one of the most
pernicious impacts of cancel culture is
not that it tries to take down people
like JK Rowling or Ricky Gervais you
know these people are uncancelable in
many ways they're too big they're too
famous they're too rich they can't be
canceled
but what it does do is it sends a
message to the rest of society it has
this chilling effect where it says to
where everyone else listen if even JK
Rowling one of the most important
cultural figures in modern Britain can
be subjected to rape threats and death
threats and vile misogyny on a daily
basis simply for saying that biology is
real and women are women and women
should have their their own rights
imagine what could happen to you imagine
what could be done to you a lowly
ordinary woman or man who has a normal
job imagine how much you will suffer if
you say the same thing so cancel culture
casts this Shadow over everyone's lives
and it discourages people from saying
what they believe to be true so I have
an element of sympathy I think with
those people who feel that they cannot
speak out because the culture now is so
intense and so intolerant and so
ferociously sensorious that people feel
that the consequences of speaking out
are too severe so I think across the
board the way in which these things get
institutionalized are firstly through
the lobbying of people who really
believe them the cowardice of the
political establishment who won't stand
up for reason and then the
understandable reluctance of ordinary
people to put their head above the
parapet but you also think that cancel
culture is not really the right way to
describe what's going on on there's
something else it's possibly a more
nuanced analysis of the situation could
you expand upon that please Brendan yeah
so in the introduction to the book I
make the point that I I'm frustrated
with the term cancel culture I use it
all the time it's a very convenient term
the public understands what it means I
hate this idea that the public doesn't
know what wokeness is or what cancel
culture is everyone has an instinctive
understanding of what these things are
so Council culture is a useful term it
has people recognize what it what it
stands for but I but the point I make in
my book is is that it's not sufficient
to describe the problems that we face
today because I think a term like cancel
culture it's become it's become almost
kind of quaint a kind of cute term it's
kind of quite light and quite flimsy it
gives the impression that the problem we
face today is the occasional
cancellation of well-known people the
occasional attempt to cancel you guys
from speaking or performing your comment
or from preventing Kathleen stock from
speaking Oxford University we're
encouraged to think that that's the key
problem that is a very serious problem
which we should always confront but I
think what we're living through is a
counter Enlightenment a reversal of
Enlightenment values themselves an
assault on reason and truth and freedom
of speech and freedom of conscience so
it runs it's it's like the term Nanny
State I've never really liked the term
Nanny State because it sounds like Mary
Poppins it sounds too flimsy to describe
the way in which the Contemporary State
thinks it has the right to intervene in
your life and tell you what to eat how
many times you should exercise how you
should raise your children I uh the
argument I make in the book is we need
new terms to describe this intense
authoritarianism and this reversal of
the enlightened values and the
commitment to reason that Define modern
society for a long time it's just such a
great point because the term cancel
culture it doesn't encapsulate what's
going on and one of the things that I
see coming down the path and I think a
lot of people do is there's this rise in
misogyny and there's a real rise in
homophobia and it's really worrying
because you see some of the old tropes
that we used to see in the 80s suddenly
you start seeing them again and it
starts being Resurrected I I couldn't
agree more you know one of the things I
find most frustrating as an anti-woke
person is that people think if you
criticize wokeness if you criticize
political correctness you must be an old
white conservative man who wants to
there's nothing wrong by the way with
being an old white conservative man more
power to you guys and you want to turn
the clock back to the 1950s women in the
kitchen
homosexuals living in shame living in
the shadows
um you know to to a past that they think
was better than what we have now for me
it couldn't be more different the reason
I'm worried about wokeness is because I
think it's undoing all the great
Progressive gains of the 1960s and the
1970s women's Liberation Racial equality
color blindness as an approach to
Everyday Life
um Gay Liberation all those great things
that happened in the 60s and the 70s
where we said to ourselves listen people
should live as they want to live uh
black people and white people should be
judged absolutely equally within Society
there should be no racial judgment
whatsoever all women should have the
same rights as men all those positive
leaps forward I think are now threatened
by the culture of wokeness so wokeness
depicts itself as the heir to the Civil
Rights Movement but I think it is the
usurper of the Civil Rights Movement so
it now says that you should judge people
by color rather than character you
should obsess over race you should wear
racial goggles every single day white
people are privileged black people are
in pain they're they're victims and
that's how you need to judge these
racial categories it is anti-women it
has rehabilitated misogyny look at the
vile abuse that gender critical
feminists get or the way in which
um supposedly woke trans activists want
to invade women's spaces and undermine
women's freedom of Association and it is
homophobic we now have a situation which
is almost unbelievable where young
lesbians and young gay men young gay
boys 15 16 17 years old
the vast majority of whom would have
gone on to become homosexual adults
perfectly happy are now being subjected
to Medical intervention hormonal
correction
if you're a young woman who fancies
Other Woman you must be a man if you're
a young man who is attracted to other
young men you must really be a woman
let's correct you let's give you the
medicine let's change your body so that
it Accords with your sexual feelings
that is what they do in Iran Iran is
second only to Thailand in terms of uh
gender reassignment surgery and that's
not because Iran is a great pro-trans
hip country it's because it is violently
homophobic and it would prefer to turn
gay men into women and lesbians into men
rather than have gay men and lesbians in
its Society we're now doing the same
thing in the west so the reason I'm
concerned about wokeness is because I
think it represents a an almost violent
reversal of the wonderful positive
Progressive liberal gains of the 60s and
the 70s and the 80s and and that's my
key problem with it and the but the
problem is as well is that in many ways
it's very one tension though isn't it
that's part of the problem because
you're fighting against good intentions
it is they think they're well
intentioned yes absolutely and they um
if if I were to say to them what I just
said to you guys they would be horrified
they do genuinely think that they're in
the same world as Martin Luther King and
Rosa Parks I mean you know
I don't want to be crude about it but
they genuinely think that fighting for
the right of a biological male to go
into a woman's bathroom and sit down on
the toilet and do his business is the
same as Rosa Parks fighting for the
right to sit on wherever the hell she
wanted to on the bus
they genuinely think they are the same
thing and what I want to say to them is
they are not the same thing Rosa Parks
when she won sat on the front of the bus
and refused to move she was striking a
blow not only for her her own dignity
but for the rights of people regardless
of their race regardless of their skin
color to engage in public life as they
choose that was a an incredibly
important and positive moment in in
modern society when a biological male
demands the right to go into a woman's
bathroom
he is being anti-social he is intruding
upon other people's already one freedoms
he is actually trying to turn Society on
his head by saying I should be able to
do whatever I want whenever I want
regardless of the consequences
regardless of how it makes women feel
regardless of whether women feel
threatened or not so I just think they
are wrong when they think that they are
The Heirs to those great movements of
the 60s and 70s and the argument I would
make to them is look I know you think
you're doing good you you feel well
intentioned but the movement that you
are part of is having an incredibly
destructive impact on people's freedoms
freedom of speech women's rights gay
rights and Racial equality and other
things that I thought we had already
agreed were good things
hey KK do you like trigonometry of
course I do incredible interviews
fascinating guests phenomenal live shows
and hilarious raw streams in that case
you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant
content that's right you get the chance
to win incredible prizes ask our
phenomenal guests your questions access
extra content and now the only place to
watch our Roars on catch-up is on locals
our war shows still go out at 7 pm UK
time 2 p.m Eastern as normal but if you
want to watch some after this time then
you're gonna need to sign up to our
locals Ross have now become too spicy to
stay on YouTube so they're only
available to watch back on our locals
page all you need to do to sign up is
click on the link below this video and
for just seven dollars a month you have
access to All of This brilliant content
seven dollars a month even for someone
of my persuasion that's a bargain see
fuel on locals
I think it's impossible to win that
argument
in the environment that we operate in
now for precisely the reason you
identified earlier which is if this is a
counter Enlightenment which I think is
the perfect way to describe it
then the concept of Truth itself ceases
to have the definition that it has had
for hundreds of years now
um and so if a man can transform the
truth of his Nature by incantation as
I'm fond of saying you know Abracadabra
Stacy now now he's a woman
then then all of the things that you've
said don't matter because he is Rosa
Parks yeah right
so the question I want to ask you
Brandon it's one that I've been
wrestling with and we've been wrestling
won the show for some time is
if this is a counter Enlightenment what
does it say about us and what does it
say particularly about the role of
religion in society because I see a lot
of people now and I think quite rightly
going
maybe we were a little bit too quick to
throw away the religious
Traditions with the bath water of
religious Dogma right maybe we were a
little too eager to throw down all the
things that came from the past maybe in
seeking to liberate gay people and women
and ethnic minorities and so on from
from the stifling oppression that they
were experiencing we actually decided
that it is in fact our mission to
constantly tear down everything that
comes from the past and so of course we
must do this now what does it what does
it say about the current moment and the
religious element particularly Keen to
hear your thoughts on that that's such
an interesting question and I feel so
torn on a question like that because one
day I wake up and I feel really radical
I feel like a revolutionary leftist
because I think to myself I want to tear
down the House of Lords which is
undemocratic and I want to
um you know have this extraordinary
amount of industrialization and progress
and I want Africa to have exactly the
same kind of life that we have in the
west I want that kind of revolutionary
forwarding of capitalist society and
industrial society so some days I wake
up and I think I feel very revolutionary
other days I wake up and I feel quite
conservative because I see the idea of
motherhood being torn down and the idea
that a bloke can breastfeed his baby
which is an obscenity in my view and I
see
um schools being bent to the uh woke
ideology and kids being taught that all
this lgbtq plus alphabet crap excuse my
language
um and and I think I don't I'm not in
favor of that and I feel very
conservative in fact in relation to
education because in my view education
is about Society transmitting the best
of its knowledge the best of its
Traditions to the Next Generation it is
not the role of schools to inculcate
kids with woke ideas and political
correctness so when I isn't it though
because if the role of schools are to
implicate the ideas of the society and
wokeness is the elite ideology
it is the purpose of schools well yeah
but then that needs to be turned on its
head yeah and and what when you see my
point though I do see your point and
what we need to get back to this is why
you know when you see um Muslim parents
in Manchester at the moment protesting
against lgbtq education
we've got all the complaints documented
a child said to his teacher
my mom's gonna have a baby boy the
teacher sent a child you don't know what
that baby is he'll decide it's gender
when it grows up
we have been living
um side by side with the gay community
we have we have the gay gay Capital as
they call it Canal Street you know in
the city center we've been living side
by side we work together there's never
been any issues with you know the LGBT
community the concerns are with the
Safeguard and inappropriateness and the
age appropriate content that we're we're
seeing is being pushed down the throats
of our children and it's not even
remaining in the pshe or the re
um subjects it's been it's been spread
across the board you know it's going
into art it's going into maths I don't
understand for the life of me why it's
it's going down this route Muslim
parents in Birmingham did it uh four or
five years ago as well and they got
loads of flack including from the left
which is usually very sympathetic to
Muslim parents but they got loads of
flack um there are huge uprisings of
minority parents in America at the
moment Muslims Armenians Latinos
African-Americans and of course white
parents as well gathering at school
Gates saying stop telling our kids there
are 72 genders I am completely on the
side of those people I'm not a religious
person I'm not naturally a conservative
person but I'm completely on the side of
those people because what they're saying
is very positive which is that we should
not be telling kids that there are a
million genders and we should not be
teaching them how to give blow jobs and
we should not be doing all these
perverse weird things we should not have
the pride flagging bathrooms you can put
it wherever you want outside of the
classroom but not in the classroom you
should be teaching kids the three R's
Reading Writing arithmetic you should be
teaching them the history of their
country you should be teaching them how
to be good citizens how to be
knowledgeable so I'm completely on their
side so I think
um I do feel torn in relation to the
question that you raise because on the
one hand there are things I want to tear
down there are things I want to rip
apart there is a revolutionary spirit I
still have I want to say the unsayable
as the subtitle to my book suggests but
on the other hand there are things I
think it's important for us to preserve
and one of the things that's important
for us to preserve is scientific reason
the idea of Truth the idea of
universalism all these things that we
benefited from in relation to the
enlightenment I think those things are
worth preserving but in relation to the
religious question
I'd be interested to hear what what your
thinking is on on that because I feel
torn on that too because on the one hand
the issue I always had with the new
atheists like Richard Dawkins and
um to a certain extent Christopher
Hitchens who I'm a huge fan of
um my issue with the new atheism is that
it was in many ways it was about mocking
religious people it was about mocking
these stupid rednecks and chavs who and
Irish Catholics which is my background
who believe in God you know uneducated
ignorant people
um and it was about basically saying
that the idea that humankind is special
that we were designed that we are above
everything else is a ridiculous idea and
what I want to do is find a humanistic
way to make the same argument I want to
find because I don't believe in God and
I am not a religious person even though
I was brought up religiously what I'm
interested in is finding a a post god
humanistic way to say yes humankind is a
superior species we are different to
every other living creature on this
planet there is something special about
us there is something wondrous about us
it's like I want to defend the idea of
Wonder the mystery of how human beings
are so incredibly intelligent and
morally inclined so the question then
becomes do you need God to do that or
can can you do that in a postcard
environment and I think that's the
struggle lots of us are facing that's
why I brought up the question because
when I was John Peterson had me on his
podcast he grilled me about this for
three hours and we went around and
around I wrote a piece on my sub stack
recently called the atheism delusion I
don't know if you saw that
um so I'm thinking about this quite a
lot now and it's
my answer on a pragmatic level forget
the philosophical level and pragmatic
level is this we we have a society in
which many many people are not religious
and they also require the same things
that we all require which is meaning and
purpose a sense of right and wrong a
sense of what's true and false a a kind
of orientation towards uh having some
kind of investment in the society that
they live in and an orientation towards
seeing it prosper and grow into the
future
um and to the extent that that can be
achieved without religion
someone like me who's agnostic and
someone like you doesn't believe in God
uh we can I'm sure totally get behind
that the problem is I do start to wonder
my issue with the new atheism is that
once you've taken God off the pedestal
and you've put the Superior in your
words human being on it
who gets to decide what's true
right because uh I can I can pull out a
scientific study that shows
transitioning is helpful to children at
this and you know do you see what I'm
saying yeah right so once truth is once
there's nothing that's kind of above us
that we all take for granted that's
passed down to us that is outside of us
yeah it's very difficult to then have
people who differ politically agree on a
certain set of values that are just
embedded in society
yeah I get that I I my argument would be
that the only way to understand truth or
arrive at truth is through freedom I
know that might sound facetious but I I
think that's very a very real Prospect
and something that people should
consider uh you know I think
um it's people have been talking for a
long time about the god-shaped hole in
modern society what do we do after God
uh how do we Define what is right and
wrong do the Ten Commandments matter
anymore in the absence of God
um so these are very real questions and
very real issues that people are talking
about and concerned about but I think
um the the point I would make is that
in my view and I know this probably is
offensive to religious people
all of those values all of those kind of
God delivered ideas that people
generally agreed on and and still do to
a certain extent
um they're really they really came from
man they really were written by man I
don't believe that there is a God I
don't believe that God did give tablets
to Moses or hide in the bush and talk to
Jesus Christ or anything like that I
don't believe that happened so these are
the creations of man in a very positive
way and we know that there is a close
link between Christianity and the
Enlightenment and between the religious
struggle for freedom of conscience and
the right to express oneself and the
right to believe what one wants to
believe and then the subsequent
development of Enlightenment values the
freedom of conscience freedom of speech
the freedom to think how you want to
think so um I'm not someone who poo-poos
religion I was brought up religiously I
was brought up as a Roman Catholic I was
an altar boy I went to Catholic schools
from the ages of 4 to 18
um I benefited from them enormously I
was educated by nuns in a school that
was built around the bottom of this
convent on top of a hill so it was great
it was wonderful and it it it benefited
me enormously but I do think that there
has to be a way in which society
precisely through exercising its freedom
to think and it's freedom to argue and
it's freedom to dissent can arrive at
something that we can generally agree to
be true
and I I do think that the uh you know
John Milton made this point in the 1640s
um he said that the the greatest crime
of censorship the reason that censorship
was so
obscene and offensive encounter to
everything that is human is because it
restricts us from discovering the truth
because what it says the the terrible
thing about censorship and I make this
point in my book is that it says you
don't have to worry your tiny little
head about what is right and wrong what
is wrong what is true and what is false
because we will decide for you some
greater Superior establishment figure
will decide on our behalf what is right
and what is wrong and he and they will
tell us and John Milton made the point
in that great moment of uh revolutionary
upheaval during the English Civil War he
said
um that's an offense against people and
the only way in which we can genuinely
believe that something is true is if we
struggle for it in the realm of freedom
and we make the argument and it is
counted and people push back against it
and we keep making the argument and
we've through that process through that
process of Freedom through that process
of Engagement we might arrive at what we
can agree generally speaking to be a
true fact the more we go through this
journey and the more I've seen these
views metastasize and spread through
Society the more I think that
the left created this stuff
and it's actually the left we're going
to solve it the left are really the ones
who are going to actually solve this
problem if it's solvable so for example
with the Trans issue the people who make
the Headway are the rosie duffields yeah
they're the JK Rawlings the people who
are the you know the nice woolly Lefty
liberals who will come out and criticize
this who are strong enough to do so I
think the right although they may
present really good ideas and their
criticisms may be incredibly valid
they're not as palatable
it's really important for left leaning
and left-wing people to stand up would
you agree on that
I would agree on that actually and I say
that as someone who I I still consider
myself a leftist most people don't know
and I'm like what I I'm a communist I
don't know what I am who knows what
these words mean anymore everything's
been thrown up in the air
um in a romantic way I still consider
myself a leftist but even as I recognize
that it has no meaning anymore because
if left left wing now whether we like it
or not left wing now means supporting
the censorship of women because they're
evil turfs it means supporting young
lesbians having double mastectomies
it means supporting canceled culture it
means brilliant hold on why do you say
this because your argument sounds a
little bit like being on the right now
means you support Hitler a little bit
like there are some people on the
fringes of the right who believe who who
are Nazis there are some people on the
fringes of the left who believe all this
crap now I hear your argument in my head
already it's in the institutions and
that's how it's being enforced but just
flesh that out for people why do you say
being on the left means that because
there will be lots of people who watch
this show who think they're on the left
that don't support that oh absolutely
like and I yeah love those people and I
I consider myself one of them yes it's
because it's it's what I mean is what
Society has defined left-wing to mean
so I don't think that that is left-wing
I don't think that is genuine genuine
leave left wing at all it's like brexit
you know that's another can of worms but
when people said that the left-wing
approach to brexit is to support the
European Union I was like no have you
forgotten Tony Ben and Peter Shaw and
Barbara Castle and all these great
historical left-wing figures from the
labor movement in the UK who were
hugely anti-european Union and in favor
of British sovereignty and British
democracy so very often what gets called
left wing is not really left wing at all
but I think the situation we have to
face up to is that we do live in a
society where the presumption at least
even if it's incorrect the presumption
is that to be left-wing means to be
pro-trans
um pro-trans kids uh pro-cancel culture
um in favor of the rehabilitation of
racial thinking although it's never
called that it's called you know let's
police white fragility let's defend um
victimized black communities
um that's what it means and and to my
mind that's a great tragedy but that is
what it means and and and
what it means to defend trans kids what
that means in the real world is
supporting the hormonal intervention
into young people's lives supporting the
surgical
mutilation if I can say it of young
lesbians of young women which I think is
a grotesque tragedy and I hope in 20 or
30 years time people will look back in
horror and look at it as a controversy
on on a scale of the thalidomide
controversy that Society could knowingly
consciously do this without having the
restrictions and the uh and the common
sense in place
um so I don't think of any of that as
left-wing but that is what left wing has
come to mean so I think those of us who
think we're lefty or liberal or you know
chilled out or counter-cultural we have
to Grapple with that we have to Grapple
with the fact that that's what it it has
come to mean which I think is a problem
that doesn't mean do you think that's a
smear because there are times where I do
actually think that's a smear because
when people go oh you're on the right
therefore that means that you hate black
people that means that you mean this I
mean you go well that doesn't mean any
of those things that's a really
ridiculous thing to say
yes it is
um
but I I think it's it it could it can
become a smear it can become a smear if
you if you caricature it too much but we
do have to face up to the fact that just
in a very measurable provable way
the people who now Define themselves as
left-wing are pro-eu they're pro-trans
they're pro-trans surgery they tend to
be pro-cancel cultural although they're
obviously exceptions
um that is what it means and it's worth
arguing against that it's worth saying
in my view it's always worth saying that
the left used to be counter-cultural
used to be libertine it used to be very
much in favor of Freedom
um you go back to the French Revolution
which is where the word left comes from
people who stood on the left side of the
assembly and people who stood on the
right side of the assembly the people
who are on the left side of the assembly
in France the the Parliamentary assembly
were the most radical the most in favor
of Freedom the most in favor of
individual sovereignty a national
sovereignty and and revolutionary ideas
that's where it comes from but it has
changed enormously and one of the things
I find interesting about the
Contemporary left in the UK and other
countries too
is their distance from Ordinary People
the distance from Working Class People
because the left used to be the one
section of political society that was in
touch with ordinary people that wanted
to fight for their economic interests
and their cultural interests and their
rights
it's now the complete opposite if you
talk to a supposed Lefty now they within
five minutes they will be raging about
Gammon right which basically means the
lower orders they will be raging about
brexit voters the low information masses
they did they don't know what they're
doing they're ignorant they're
xenophobic they're racist they're obese
uh they're feckless all those ideas that
you would once have heard from right
hard right Wingers you now tend to hear
from people who claim to be left-wing so
I do think we have to face up to the
fact that we live in a world in which
those terms of right and left
probably mean very different things to
what we would understand them
traditionally to mean and that's the
world I think we have to Grapple with
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
and Brendan uh picking up on what
Francis said earlier about many of these
problems coming from the left I'm
curious you mentioned the nanny State
earlier and I would describe what I
think people mean by that is a growing
and increasing interference in the lives
of ordinary people in their individual
decisions about how to live their life
how to raise their children you know all
sorts of other things from the
government
and that seems to me to be an idea
that's spreading incredibly rapidly and
wherever you look I mean you look at
your gas prices go up the government's
got to give people a handout interest
rates go up the government's got to step
in this has happened the government the
government we're all it's almost like
whenever there's a problem now it's
always the government that's supposed to
fix them and that seems to me to have
two consequences yes on the one hand it
means you are more protected but the
people who protect you it's like your
dad saying to you of 15 you can do
whatever you want when you move out
right you can do whatever you want when
you're not living under my roof and
we're all increasingly now living under
the government's roof is it any surprise
that the government is telling us don't
say this don't think this don't go here
don't drink this don't consume that
that's a good point I think that the
more that we get sucked into the remit
of government assistance and you will
get sucked into the remit of government
control I mean that's the logic of that
um kovid was a good example covet is a
very good example of that the whole
lockdown idea I think
um yes we live in a situation in which
tragically I think lots of people look
very often their first instinct is to
look to the government for assistance I
do think that speaks to a great fraying
of community solidarity and Community
connections you could have gone you
could go back 40 50 60 years and if
people were hard up for cash or they
didn't know how to make ends meet or
they didn't have anyone to look after
their kids or had to go out to work you
would turn to your neighbors you return
to your family you would turn to those
people around you
um you know my parents are Irish
immigrants they came to this country in
1970. the IDE and they were incredibly
young the idea that they would ever have
turned to the state I mean there were
restrictions on their ability to do that
but the idea they would ever have done
that was unimaginable unimagined it
would have been the last on their list
of things that they would do instead
they struck up friendships they mixed in
other Irish circles you you would say
who might look after my kids who might
do this all those things I think are
fraying and one of the consequences of
that fraying is that people do turn to
government and and and then you start to
develop this assumption that the
government will always look after you
but the point that we need to remind
people of is that the government very
rarely has our best interests at heart
and that's not because they're
particularly evil or anything like that
but just because it's it's the Machinery
of government it has lots of things to
do it's not it doesn't particularly care
about the individual or the struggling
mum or the the dad who needs someone to
look after his kids or whatever else it
might be
um so the way in which I think people
feel ever more reliant on the government
for handouts for welfare for child care
for lockdown protecting us from disease
whatever else it might be I think that
speaks to a a tragic hollowing out of
the solidarity that once knitted people
together and not only did it knit people
together but it knitted people together
in opposition to external forces who
said we'll look after you but we knew
they wouldn't
so the absence of those kind of
community connections and that social
connectedness is I think one of the
things that underpins the nanny State
and the lockdown is a perfect example of
that because I think what the lockdown
did is that it further corroded social
connectedness because what it it
criminalized social connectedness it was
a crime to go outside of your house and
to knock on your neighbor's door and to
say shall I buy you some food
shall I come in and keep you company and
watch TV for the night
um shall I go to my sister's house
across town and help her look after her
kids they were criminal offenses so one
of the chapters in my book is on Covert
as metaphor and the point I make is that
the the tragedy of lockdown is that it
institutionalized the idea that human
beings are toxic we are diseased we are
a problem not only to ourselves but to
other people and we need to be
controlled and cajoled and kept in our
own space and and forced to behave in a
certain way so I think going forward the
impact of the nanny state is going to
get worse and worse and we need to
develop some really good arguments to
counter it and it's also betrays a
certain kind of helplessness within
people where people feel that they're no
longer in control of their lives and
they feel completely disempowered
absolutely so it it you know when I see
the nanny State great you know there is
this argument that I see on sections of
the right which is you know the sheeple
you know the the idiot public who bought
into lockdown and who buy into the nanny
State and who nod along to all this
stuff that we're getting told
I feel so uncomfortable with all of that
stuff it really to me it it echoes the
arguments that you hear from section to
the left about the low information
public the stupid brexit voter the you
know the stupid Northerners didn't know
what they were voting for there was that
great placard in Westminster at one of
the pro-brexit rallies where a woman had
a placard saying
um I'm a dumb northerner who knew what
she was voting for so there was that on
the left you see those elitist arguments
but you also see them
um from sections of the right in terms
of the sheeple the idiots the the the
the dumb masses
um and I'm I I feel uncomfortable with
that because
as someone who adheres to the old
ancient Roman phrase nothing human is
alien to me I try to understand where
people are coming from and I think one
of the reasons people feel
that they can't turn to their neighbors
or they have to rely on the government
or they have to follow the lockdown
rules or they have to do all these
things is precisely because they have
been so ferociously atomized and
alienated from everyone else and told
constantly that they don't know what
they're doing and the state does know
what it's doing if you have that message
drilled into you again and again and
again there is there is going to come a
point where you start to lack the
confidence to act on your own volition
and to act on your own judgment and I
think that one of the points I make in
my book is that that's what we need to
recover we need you know the
enlightenment is built on the idea that
people know how to run their lives if I
would encourage all your listeners and
viewers to read uh Emmanuel Kant he
wrote an essay Emmanuel Kant is a very
difficult Enlightenment thinker to read
it's it's hard to work out what he's
talking about but he wrote an essay
called what is Enlightenment which you
can google and find online it's really
short it could be published today he
basically says
um there are too many Apron Strings
Attached to Ordinary People we have
Physicians who tell us what to eat we
have spiritual leaders to tell us what
to think we have books that tell us how
to behave we need to push all of that
aside and think for ourselves and use
our own moral reason and moral judgment
to act in the world and to act in our
own lives that was the enlightenment
idea and so when we talk about living in
an encounter Enlightenment The Nanny
state is an expression of the the
counter Enlightenment the lockdown was
an expression of that counter
Enlightenment canceled culture is an
expression of their counter
Enlightenment all of these ideologies
which constantly say to us you don't
know what's best you don't know what to
think you don't know how to behave so we
have to tell you so it basically is
about recovering some of those that
Enlightenment self-confidence there's
one thing that no one wants to say as
part of that conversation that I feel
needs to be said which is it's not true
that everyone knows how best to run
their life what is true is that it's
preferable to behave as if that's true
and to bear the consequences of your own
bad decisions yourself
but we don't seem to ever air that part
of it we don't ever say you messed up
and now you're in debt and now you've
got to pay it off
right you messed up and you did this and
now you got to take responsibility and
if we're not willing to say that nothing
else works
this whole thing breaks down yeah that's
a really good point I think most people
know what's best for themselves and
their families I trust that you two know
what's best in your lives and that's
because you don't know as well right
yeah
um most people that you meet in the
public on the street you know you know
this from your own lives that people you
know people you know who are not in the
public eye at all they know what they're
doing they know how to raise their kids
most people do know but you raise a
really important point which is that
some people are stupid let's be honest
about it some people don't know they
make bad judgments
um but even that I think is part of the
Enlightenment Freedom that I'm talking
about right it's the right to make wrong
choices and actually John Stuart Mill
talks about this in on Liberty published
in the 1860s I think
um where he says that even if it's true
that the government has a better idea
than this person this this Dad or this
mum or this in this drunken on the
street even if it's true that there
government has a better view of that
person's life than that person
themselves still that person must be
allowed to make their own judgments
because only through the process of
making your own choices making your own
judgments making your own mistakes that
you might potentially learn something
and that you might actually correct
yourself and you might actually think I
need to improve and some people don't
some people just
I suppose let me just push back on that
so we spend a lot of time in America and
we love America but if you go to San
Francisco or any city in the United
States you see homeless people yeah
wandering around drug addicted clearly
incapable of functioning on any level
any level whatsoever the argument is
well it's cruel to keep these people in
you know Mental Hospitals or drug
counseling they should be free to live
their lives that doesn't really work on
a purely practical level because what it
leads to is San Francisco yeah and that
isn't good for anybody
yeah or San Francisco as our mutual
friend Michael Schellenberg who calls it
I don't disagree I think there is a
point at which
um
the defense of Freedom becomes something
else it becomes the defense off
um self-destruction
it's very we have to be very careful in
working out where that line is but you
see it I've seen it in San Francisco
I've seen it in Los Angeles when last
time I was in Los Angeles I was
horrified it's every big city in America
including in red states by the way
unbelievable I was in Salt Lake City a
few weeks ago that there's just people
wandering around harassing people
sitting Outdoors just mentally ill
people and they're not they're not
that's not Freedom no no that's not
freedom I agree and um I was really
shocked the last time I was in LA isn't
you know we have homeless problems in
London and we have poverty problems in
London but La is off the scale you know
there are tents and Tents and on the
streets and people living on the streets
you don't even know some of them are
alive or not you're literally walking
past people who could be dead it's the
it's third world conditions it's it's
really shocking if you say that I lived
in the third world this does not right
right in Russia in Ukraine in Armenia in
Uzbekistan I I have never seen anything
like this in the third world it's
horrendous there's no question about
that there are smaller scale versions of
it I think in Europe
um I go to Ireland a lot and I go to
Dublin on my way to to Galway which is
the place I mostly go to and even in
Dublin you'll see some of these problems
expressed in a smaller way you'll see
long user people for Methadone and so on
on certain streets and so there are lots
of problems
I think the issue there is that I think
some people confuse Freedom with
non-judgmentalism that's the problem and
so I am I I am a fervent defender of
freedom freedom of speech freedom of
choice freedom of conscience freedom of
Association the vast majority of human
beings should enjoy those freedoms and
have every ability to do so but there is
a section of society that who fall under
the radar or who who
um fall on hard times and I think what
contemporary Western Elites do is that
they use the language of freedom to
justify those people's self-destruction
so they say it's their free choice relax
if they want to defecate in public and
shoot up in public and do whatever else
they want to do in public that's freedom
but that's not Freedom that's
degradation that is self-degradation but
it's also social degradation that
individual should not be experiencing
such horrific living conditions and the
other people in that Society whether
it's San Francisco or Dublin or whatever
else it might be should not have to
observe those living conditions so
that's another failure of solidarity
another failure of sense another failure
of reason and there are situations I
think extreme situations in which
society should make a judgment which is
very unfashionable these days and should
say we judge that these people their
behavior is so self-destructive and uh
also socially destructive that action
needs to be taken to try to get them on
the straight and narrow sometimes that
will work sometimes it won't but the
effort needs to be made but it's the
unwillingness to make judgments the
criminalization of moral judgment let
everything happen let everything go you
know don't be judgy that's well once you
take away truth you take away right and
wrong and then you can't make a judgment
yeah exactly yeah and and it's also as
well because we talk about nanish State
and look I'm in agreement with you on
pretty much everything that you say
Brendan but there are elements of the
nanny state that we need you know
Islamic fundamentalists need to be
tracked
they need you know they need to
something needs to be done you know
there's at some point the state needs to
step in do you see what I mean that you
can't just let people
just be completely free there needs to
be checks and balances and I think where
the discussion gets really interesting
is where we talk about what checks what
balances how much freedom and actually
when does the State needs to step in
because I feel that the libertarian
argument not saying that you're
presenting it of just maximum Freedom
whatever else
it doesn't work in reality
I think one of the issues I I don't
disagree with that and I think one of
the questions in relation to Islamic
fundamentalism is the question of when
you intervene so I am very much I'm So
Pro freedom of speech that I'm gonna say
something no no no no I'm So Pro freedom
of speech that I even think Islamic
radicals should be allowed to go on
campuses and make their speeches and so
on and and say you know stupid kaffirs
and backward regressive non-muslims you
know beat your wives I'm a real free
speech extremist I think people should
be allowed to say those things
um and I know that makes some people
uncomfortable but that is what I believe
but then there is the question of when
does the state have the right to
intervene so there does obviously come a
point where extremist ideas and
extremist ideology crosses the line into
some form of behavior some form of
action some form of conspiracy and if
you look at the failures over the
Manchester Arena bombing I've read all
three of those inquiry reports and I
encourage everyone to read them it's
absolutely astonishing the failures are
at every level the failure to clock that
the bomber was planning this they
completely failed to do that the failure
to clock on the night itself that this
young fellow was walking around with a
massive rucksack
for hours before he detonated it and in
fact one of the people who worked at the
Manchester Arena said he didn't accost
this young man because he was afraid of
being accused of racism
that's where the uh obsession with
islamophobia gets you you don't even
want to walk up to a young bloke with a
rucksack at 9 00 pm at a Manchester
Arena Ariana Grande concert in case
someone calls you racist and then the
failure after the fact and the way in
which we don't talk about that bombing
we don't talk about Islamic radicalism
we don't talk about Islamic terrorism
because you might offend apparently the
Muslim Community so there are huge
failures across the board from the state
and from society in relation to radical
Islam but I do think it's worth tussling
with a question of when it is
justifiable for the state to intervene
because they think you've gone beyond
rhetoric into something else but the
broader point I would make on freedom in
response to your question Francis is
that
um I think it's an important Point
um freedom is not necessarily nice
it's not necessarily
a good comfortable thing sometimes
Freedom gives rise to horrible things
and ugly ideas and racist ideas and
Prejudiced ideas and hate speech I'm one
of those people who thinks that even hey
speech shouldn't be censored because the
best way to challenge those regressive
ideologies is in the public realm it's
in the open free space where you can
deploy reason and Truth to counter the
arguments of people who we all agree are
backward and regressive and Prejudiced
and dangerous
um you know the classic example is
Holocaust denial that's banned in many
European countries it was banned in
France around 25 years ago because it's
a racist ideology we all know it's a
racist ideology and France now has one
of the worst problems in Europe of
anti-Semitism it has one of the worst
problems of Holocaust denial for various
social reasons
um and I think the censorship
contributed to that because if you force
these things underground you create a
situation where they can fester and grow
and they can take hold amongst isolated
communities in particular and in
France's case immigrant communities who
feel cut off from the mainstream and
they latch onto these dangerous
ideologies
um so freedom
is can be uncomfortable and it can feel
dangerous and it can feel like you're
allowing all sorts of problematic ideas
to have free reign and what are we going
to do with them but that is always
preferable one of the points I make in
my book is that freedom of speech is
always preferable to censorship because
censorship is far more likely to unleash
Prejudice and violence than freedom of
speech ever is and and it's worth
remembering that and we saw that it's a
great point because we saw over covert
with the suppression of the lab League
discussion and actually what happened
and it seemed to me was that we tended
to get this explosion of conspiracy
theories yeah where people were actually
saying a variety of different things and
as a result of that you know that people
are scandemic and all the rest of it and
you saw people who I regarded as friends
and at one point being perfect perfectly
reasonable
suddenly descend into a form of Madness
in many ways I couldn't agree more and
it's one of my big concerns coming out
of the covert era is the way in which I
I actually think that the the um covert
deniers the people who think that it was
a scandemic I'm sorry but I think what
they've done is unforgivable because
they have trounced the very important
discussion we need to have about
lockdown we need to have a very
important social open discussion about
whether the lockdown was the right
policy
um when is it justifiable to lock down
Society did we go too far did we have
too many
um does it need to be institutionalized
in law or can we have a volunteeristic
approach as they did in Sweden these are
important discussions but what the
scandamic lobby have done and the
anti-vaxx lobby and and others who think
the wef has got its puppeteering hands
behind all of this
they have um blown apart that discussion
by polluting it with ideas that are just
cranky and conspiratorial and crazy so I
hold I have no truck with these people
at all and it's won me few friends and
lost me some followers but I don't care
because it's important to defend reason
and truth and another example is the
Ukraine issue I'm afraid to say I I
think Ukraine has now started to come
become bound together with the lockdown
conspiracism you know zelenski is just a
puppet he's just a wef actor he used to
be an actor oh that's suspicious
um you know you know that is about the
sophistication level that is what it is
and you know you you know why are we
supporting Ukraine why are we sending
them Weaponry why are we doing this it's
cynicism that masquerades as criticism
and it makes me very uncomfortable and
what I want to say to these people is
look I I agree with some of your points
in relation to the nanny state or
wokeness or the trans ideology and so on
but you lose me when you jeopardize
important discussions about lockdown
important discussions about Russia's
barbaric Imperial invasion of Ukraine by
introducing all these cynical elements
introducing the idea that these are
conspiratorial measures that were
introduced by people that we have no
control over because that's undemocratic
it's illiberal and it feeds into the
very climber that I think people like us
are supposed to be challenging there you
go the title of this episode is going to
be Brendan O'Neill controlled opposition
that's me Brendan's great tally back on
the show before we head over to locals
where our fans will ask you their
questions uh tell us what is the one
thing we're not talking about as a
society that you think we really should
be
I always forget that you guys asked this
question I know even though you remind
me and we've done it before I'm never
really prepped
um I think well the first thing to say
is that we are now finally talking about
the things that we should be talking
about we are talking about the trans the
transing of kids we are talking about uh
the problem of lockdown so there are
some good things that we're talking
about
um I think we do need to talk more we
are talking a lot about freedom of
speech but I do think we need to talk
about it more I mean it is the issue
that I am most obsessed with I do think
we need to start to dig down into terms
of what we mean by freedom of speech how
expansive we think it should be does it
apply to everyone does it apply to our
radical islamist friends
um there is still a discussion to be had
I think about what freedom of speech
means one of the things that worries me
about the freedom of speech question of
the moment is that very often people are
defending me speech rather than free
speech and I fear that even gender
critical feminists and I'm a huge fan of
gender critical feminists they will
often go to the barricades in defense of
gender critical feminist freedom of
speech but if you were talking about
Dapper laughs going onto a campus and
making a few kind of color jokes
or some right winger going on campus and
saying I don't like all these immigrants
coming over here
they would probably go quite quiet so I
still think even though freedom of
speech and canceled culture and all
those things have become part of common
discussion there still needs to be a
more rigorous everyday debate and
Analysis of how important freedom of
speech and how far it should go
brilliant Brendan thank you for coming
back we're going to head over to locals
make sure you get the book of Heretics
Manifesto and we'll see you on locals
monitor right and when is it wrong to
Ally yourself with groups are
ideologically different
when you have certain common causes but
strongly disagree on other issues
[Music]